today I'm going to show you something
that's never been done before I'm going
to take an angular 5 progressive web app
make it 100% optimized for search engine
crawlers like Googlebot and Bing BOTS
make all of your routes readable by
social media link bots make it fully
compatible with angularfire - or any
other asynchronous data source and we're
going to do this all without ever using
angular universal we're going to do this
with a brand new library from the Google
Chrome team called render Tron if you're
not familiar with headless chrome or
render Tron I recommend watching Sam
Lee's talk at polymer summit 2017 it is
truly mind-blowing if you've ever
struggled with client-side JavaScript
frameworks and search engine
optimization what I'm going to show you
today is how to use this tool with
angular 5 and firebase cloud functions
and you're going to be very surprised at
how easy this is to implement with an
existing angular app I have a full
working demo deployed to firebase
hosting that you can test and validate
and I'm also going to be sharing all of
the source code on angular firebase com
if you're new here make sure to
subscribe and if you want to keep this
content free and frequent consider
becoming a pro supporter let's take a
closer look at how the system is going
to work we have just a regular angular
progressive web app deployed to firebase
hosting then we have our render tron app
on the right render tron is just a
Chrome browser that can run on the
server
meaning it can render your site just
like a normal user would and then it can
return that data back to a bot that
wants to read the meta tags or any
asynchronous data that was loaded into
the page from there we're going to set
up a cloud function to serve as
middleware that will determine if a user
is a bot or an actual human that should
receive the normal angular app let's say
someone shares a link and the Facebook
bought wants to crawl your site to show
a preview of that link the cloud
function will route the request to
render Tron first then respond to the
Facebook bot with a fully rendered page
this means you can create meta tags
dynamically or load data asynchronously
and it can still be read by any kind of
bot if a regular human comes to visit
the site it's going to skip render Tron
and just serve the angular app directly
if this user decides to share a link
from your app in social media it's going
to show any meta tags associated with
that page the chrome team has an
instance of render Tron deployed which
you can use now for your own app however
it's not recommended for production use
I'm going to show you how to clone the
project and deploy it to App Engine if
you do want to use this in production
it's a docker I spray
so you can actually deploy it to any
back-end that you want but for testing
you can just use the instance that
Google has deployed it exposes a very
simple API you simply pass it the URL
that you want to read and it will render
and serialize that URL it listens to the
initial page load as well as any a
synchronous events and network calls to
load additional data into the page it
gives you up to 10 seconds to render the
page but it will send the response as
soon as the pages finish rendering so
now that we know how to render Tron
works let's go ahead and build an
angular app that can actually put this
to use the first thing I'm going to do
is generate a new app and make sure to
include the routing module then I'm
going to go into the index.html file and
add some meta tags for Twitter and Open
Graph if you're not familiar with meta
tags they just tell link bots how to
display your page to show a twitter card
we just give it a title description and
image if someone links this page Twitter
will know exactly which image to display
and the description to show in the
Twitter platform itself the meta tags
I'm showing you here are designed to be
a default fallback if we can't
dynamically generate them they should
convey general information about the
homepage of your app now we want these
meta tags to change for each individual
component that's loaded by the router so
we're gonna do that by generating an SEO
service the first thing I'm doing is
importing that meta service from angular
which just is able to set meta tags
dynamically in the head of the document
and then we'll inject that in the
constructor and I'm setting up a
configuration object here you're
probably gonna want to customize this
for your own app but it just takes named
arguments that you can override with
your own configuration object the whole
point of this method is to avoid
repeating these meta tags over and over
again for each individual component we
can set them from the service by calling
meta update tag along with the name and
that content that we want to show the
structure of these tags will mirror the
meta tags we set an index.html and then
update them when a new component is
rendered we can set the values using
that configuration object which keeps
our code dry so we're not repeating
update tag and each individual component
I'm going through this quickly because
each update tag method is exactly the
same now let's put this service to use
in a component so I'm generating a new
component called about page I also
created a few other
components and we'll load all of these
in the router we will first import each
component then we'll add them to the
routes array each route will have a path
that's where you navigate to in the
browser and then the component that
you'll render imperatively using that
route now we need to set up a few links
so users can actually navigate to these
routes we can do that using the app
component and you should see the router
outlet at the bottom and then we'll just
do a router link for each of our paths
now for each of these components we can
generate the meta tags dynamically so
all we have to do is go into the
component type script and import the SEO
service and then during ng on an it will
call that generate tags method with the
configuration options that we want to
set so for the home page we'll set the
title and then we'll say the description
is my SEO friendly home page in angular
5 and give it an image as well then we
can switch over to the about page and do
the exact same thing so that'll set the
meta tags dynamically for any component
that's loaded by the router you can
verify this is working by opening your
app and then going into the head of the
document and you should see that meta
tags change like this each time you
navigate to a new route that's pretty
cool but I want to take this a step
further and generate the meta tags
dynamically with data loaded from the
firebase database I have another
component generated called firebase demo
that's exactly the same as all the
others but in this one we're going to
import the firebase database for this
part you need a firebase account as well
as angularfire to installed you can
follow the official instructions on the
main repo I'm going to import the
firebase database and you could also use
firestore here as well if you wanted to
then we'll need an rxjs observable as
well as the take operator first time
setting up a reference to the angular
fire object then we'll retrieve that
data as an observable then we'll inject
our SEO service as well as the angular
fire database in the constructor to make
the reference we just call DB object and
I have this data saved on the demo node
and then we get the data by calling
value changes let's quickly jump into
firebase and see what this data looks
like for this demo it looks exactly like
the data we had hard-coded in the
components earlier but we're going to
load it over the
work via firebase to set the metatags
we're going to call take one on the
observable and then subscribe to it and
with the admitted value we're going to
use our SEO service to set the meta tags
the data we get back from the
subscription will be that data we just
looked at in firebase so we can set that
title description and image meta tags so
that's all we need from angular now it's
up to render tron and firebase cloud
functions to make this SEO friendly
first I'm going to show you how to
deploy your own instance of render tron
so you can use this in production Google
may offer this as a service in the
future and I hope that they do but for
now we have to deploy our own instance
of render tron for testing this part is
completely optional so if you want to
skip this step you can go straight to
the firebase cloud function for this
demo I'm just going to clone render Tron
directly into my angular project but you
probably want to have it as a standalone
project separate from angular I'd also
like to point out that you need to have
docker installed the system requirements
vary so I'm not able to show you that
step-by-step here the next step is to CD
into that directory then run the docker
build command it will take a few minutes
to build the container but once it's
finished you should be able to run
docker run and serve it locally on your
system if you navigate to port 8080 you
should see the render tron app running
there this is great if you want to
customize render tron source code for
your specific needs if you already have
a project with firebase you can deploy
the container to App Engine with a
single command you'll first want to go
into the app yamo file and set the
number of CPU cores and memory that you
want to use if you have the Google cloud
platform command-line tools installed
you can simply call g-cloud app deploy
with your corresponding firebase project
that's going to take another few minutes
but it'll give you back a URL with your
own custom production ready version of
render tron now we're ready to create
the cloud function middleware that will
determine if the user is a bought or an
actual human you'll need both firebase
hosting and firebase functions
initialized in your project then we need
to configure hosting to use the firebase
cloud function for any URL other than
the root URL so we do that by adding it
to the rewrite section and the function
is going to be called app but before we
get into the function I'd like to point
out that render Tron has an existing
firebase
cloud function designed to work with
polymer it's not compatible with angular
but it might be worth checking out so
getting back to our app we're going to
CD in the functions directory then we're
going to install Express J S which will
give us some syntactic sugar for routing
and also a library called node fetch
then we're going to go into the
index.jsp file and import these required
libraries we're also going to import URL
from node and then set our Express app
as a variable then I'm going to set our
URL endpoints directly in the function
itself but you could also set these as
environment variables so the app URL is
going to be the URL that we deploy our
annular app to and firebase hosting and
then the render URL is the render truant
endpoint so you can use this render tron
endpoint exactly as it appears here but
if you deployed your own then you would
use your own render URL so we'll export
a function called app and that's going
to give us access to a request and
response object and we're going to use
the wild card character to catch all
routes the first thing I'm going to do
is write a couple of helper functions to
make this a little bit easier so first
we need to generate the URL from the
request so it won't be in the correct
format unless we use the node URL
library so we'll get the protocol the
main app URL then path name is the
actual route the user is trying to get
to to detect search engine crawlers and
social media bots we're going to create
a big list of known bot user agents so
probably the most famous is google bot
but Google BOTS good at executing
JavaScript so you may not even want to
include it here then we'll also set up
our social media bots that would be like
Twitter bot Facebook Linkedin slack and
many others this list isn't
comprehensive you can definitely add
additional values here to detect other
bots the way we actually detect a bot is
from its user agent header in the
request so we're going to take that
header and convert it to lowercase and
then we're going to loop over this list
of bots if we detect the substring in
the header then we're going to say the
bot was detected we can console.log it
for debugging and then we'll return true
from the function otherwise we're just
going to return false when the cloud
function is invoked the very first thing
we're going to do is run this detect bot
helper with the request header
if it returns true we'll know that we
need to send this request to render tron
first so if that's the case then we're
going to format the URL properly to send
it to our render tron endpoint we can do
that with the generate URL function we
created earlier
and then we'll call fetch to fetch the
actual URL so we call the render URL
slash bought URL and that returns a
promise then we'll get the text from
that promise that will give us a
response body that we can send back to
the actual crawler bot but we're going
to define some caching on it so we can
set the cache control header then we'll
set the very header which signals which
part of the request was important in
determining our response in this case
the user-agent header is what determines
how we build this response the last
thing we'll do is convert the body to a
string and then we can send that as a
response from the cloud function that
will be a fully rendered and serialized
web page that can be used by the actual
crawler bot if we don't detect a bot
then we just want to display the main
angular app we can do that by simply
fetching the root URL that's deployed to
firebase we can handle the response in
the same exact way we'll just turn the
body into a string and then send that as
a response from the cloud function you
could probably optimize this to be
faster but it's only going to fire when
you don't go to the root URL because of
firebase hosting priorities it will use
the index.html file when you navigate to
the root URL on your project I discussed
this in more detail in the main article
but for now we're just going to go ahead
and deploy the function so run firebase
deploy only functions then you'll also
need to create a production build for
your angular app so run ng build
production then run firebase deploy only
hosting just like magic your progressive
web app is now optimized for search
engines and can be used by link BOTS and
you didn't have to break your angular
app in the process all of this is very
cutting edge so I recommend you check
out my working demo and reach out on
slack if you have any questions for each
page in the demo there's a URL and if
you paste that into any social media
outlet you should get a link preview or
if you fetch it as a bot you should see
that fully rendered HTML
that's it for angular SEO with render
Tron if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want
advanced exclusive content related to
these topics consider becoming a pro
subscriber at angular firebase comm
you'll get a free copy of my book as
well as one on one project consulting
thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]